sites steeped in history
in fire the lead the Spanish cities
illustrious past is omnipresent
the plus am i or laid out in the
sixteenth century is a popular meeting
place it provided the model for many
market squares in Central and South
America but also the plazas in Madrid
and Salamanca
art historian maria martine specializes
in the cultural treasures of her own
city we are very proud to say we come
from by Adelaide because the city has
such a significant history and tradition
it was long spain's capital and the
residents of the royal court the Palacio
de Santa Cruz with Spain's first
Renaissance style building students once
lived in it today it houses the
university administration one of the
most important weddings in Spanish
history that a fourteen year old
Isabella of Castilla and ferdinand ii of
aragon was held in the Palacio de las
piernas known as the Catholic Monarchs
they later waged war against the Moors
in Granada and expelled Muslims and Jews
from Spain fascinated by the contrast
between the girl Isabella and her
powerful character later she took up
arms and defended her own interests her
marriage was primarily a marriage of
convenience she's a queen who went down
in history capital a story of this Plaza
was at the center of economic and
political affairs for centuries
Anna of Austria later queen of France
was born in the royal palace here across
the way the Palacio Pimentel was the
birthplace of philip ii of spain
mosaics in the entryway depict the
course of Philips life
oh yeah and if there were 300 palaces
and 50 cloisters in close proximity
peace treaties were signed with other
countries here and there were many
embassies the Spanish monarchs always
wanted to demonstrate their power with
magnificent parties for six years during
the reign of Philip the 3rd for example
by addo lead was the scene of a
never-ending party in LA
the museum displays treasures from the
old cloisters like these choir stalls
from a Benedictine monastery by a delete
was the headquarters of the Benedictine
Order whose monks were the Royal bankers
many artists also sought the favor of
the court miguel de cervantes lived here
for two years
seeking sponsors to publish the first
volume of the novel that would make him
famous Don Quixote the furnishings are
as true to the original as possible the
desk where Cervantes wrote his
masterpiece could have looked like this
CA radicals a second volume of the book
includes scenes that reflect customs and
doings at court
Cervantes witnessed several amorous
scandals here though he wasn't
personally involved in them but he did
write about them in the second volume
Cervantes is world famous
so this museum draws visitors from
around the globe who want to learn about
the adventurous authors everyday life
that's when that ele was a re read Don
Quixote in school of course and now I'm
here and what I read is suddenly reality
this is where he lived and where he
wrote part of his book and it's as if
history were coming to life it really
gives me goosebumps
hi culture history and the Spanish way
of life it's all on offer when you visit
the Royal City of bhaiyya delete